et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe froguel chercheur généticien
professeur à l'impérial college de
londres et à l'université lille 2
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france un nombre de cas positifs
au co bic a bondi de 30% en une semaine
même s'il reste plutôt à des niveaux
raisonnables en france selon vous
philippe froguel la france va rester
épargnée justement par les très mauvais
chiffres que connaissent certains
voisins européens
on a à peu près la même augmentation que
km on part de beaucoup plus bas et on
peut espérer qu'avec les mesures qui
sont prises aujourd'hui que on atteigne
pas les niveaux absolument énorme qu'on
a actuellement en allemagne avec c'est
surtout ce nombre de morts extrêmement
important puisqu'il ya plus de morts
aujourd'hui en allemagne qu'il y en a un
en angleterre comment justement vous
expliquer cette situation et 7 on va
irak elle me française en tout cas sûr
sur le plan des décès à l'hôpital
leurs enfants sont là deux choses qui se
sont complétés la première à une
vaccination qui s'est accélérée pendant
l'été
avec comme on l'a dit 51 millions de
personnes qui sont vaccinées il n'y a
plus aujourd'hui qu'une environ une
dizaine 12 m 2 pour cent de la
population qui n'est pas vaccinée pour
différentes raisons d'ailleurs et
d'autre part avec le parce qu'il est pas
un pass vaccinale mais un pass
sanitaires eh bien on a limité d'une
certaine façon à la circulation du virus
et donc les deux à la fois
ont permis d'avoir cette situation quand
même bien meilleure que dans beaucoup de
pays européens il est il normal je vais
et de dire une augmentation à l'image de
ce qui se passe ailleurs même si on part
de plus bas comment l'expliqué
aujourd'hui c'est l'immunité qui baisse
d'abord il ya l'hiver
qui est important c'est à dire que les
personnes et dans l'intérieur et ce
virus delta est très très très
contagieux moi ce que j'ai noté aussi
totalement métro que c'est commence à y
avoir des gens qui partent et plus le
masque et donc les mesures dites de
mitigation c'est à dire en fait de
l'essayer d'hercule et l'infection sont
un petit peu moins suivie qu'elle
l'était il ya trois mois et via tout ce
qui vient de l'étranger et on tient sont
pas fermées et la talent d'allemagne
d'angleterre et donc c'est mécanique
finalement ça va augmenter en france
pour l'instant ça n'a pas énormément
augmenté dans les hôpitaux et et encore
moins aux mortalités vous qui justement
connaissait bien l'angleterre puisque
vous y travaillez également à ce que
vous pensez qu'on est peut-être un peu
trop laxiste au sein de l'europe ans
quand on va au royaume uni il faut se
tester au bout du deuxième jour c'est
pas le cas en france au monde uniquement
impasse sanitaire est ce que ça suffit
aujourd'hui
en angleterre il ya eu beaucoup de cas
parce que le gouvernement de l'origine
seules à relâcher toutes ces mesures par
pierre on le voit bien dans le métro
anglais il ya peut-être 20 % des gens et
surtout des touristes tu portes qui
porte le masque
est par contre ce qu'ils ont fait et ce
qui est pas mal c'est qu'ils sont allés
chercher les gens chez eux
ceux qui n'étaient pas vaccinés et c'est
ce qu'ont fait pas en france et ils ont
aussi bien augmenter le taux de
troisième touché des gens fragiles ce
qui fait que le est à peu près
aujourd'hui à 35 milles à 40 mille cas
par jour en angleterre mais nombre de
morts
est assez stable mais il est quand même
trois fois plus élevés qu'en france
philippe froguel en france sont est
peut-être beaucoup moins puisque
désormais les terres ce ton majorité
payant
ceci explique peut-être cela qu'on teste
pas donc on isole - par par définition
alors en france en test un peu moins
maintenant depuis que les clés sont
payants mais on est peut-être mal
c'est-à-dire en angleterre tous les
toutes les femmes il reçoit des
autotests pour leurs enfants et on leur
demande très fortement de tester
eux-mêmes la à leurs enfants et puis
n'importe qui je veux dire mes enfants
qui sont des adultes et à une quête
asthmatique et bien elle reçoit cinq
tests par semaine par la poste et
qu'elle fait elle même en france ces
autos tests sont très peu fait sans
licence quand une famille très peu fait
et je ne suis pas sûr que conteste
obligatoirement les personnes les plus à
risque en tout cas celles qui ont les
premiers symptômes et et qui devrait se
tester eux-mêmes d'abord avant d'aller
dans un laboratoire art aujourd'hui
renaud muselier qui militait pour le
passeur vaccinale a fait cette sortie il
a qualifié les non-vaccinés de bombes
virale est ce que vous vous partager le
même diagnostic
c'est toujours trop compliqué
[Musique]
pour des hommes politiques que dire les
choses clairement et je dirais de
manière propre
le vaccin n'empêche pas de se faire
infecter par parti
marginal mais existante des personnes
qui ont été vaccinées et une fois qu'ils
sont infectés sont autant une bombe une
bombe infectieuses que ceux qui sont qui
ne sont pas vaccinés donc le sas dire
des approximations des choses pareilles
ne font que renforcer
la suspicion
non non on peut être être vaccinés être
affectés une fois qu'on a infecté on
peut transmettre vacciner ou pas de la
même façon que les non vaccinés fini
fort des leçons fait rare de ma part
c'est pourtant ce qu'on a on a souvent
lille contre lui le contraire que quand
on est vaccinés on transmet beaucoup
moins je connais plus le chiffre exact
mais enfin là vous venez j'avoue de
m'apprendre quelque chose ça veut dire
que quand on est vaccinés on transmet
autant le virus aussi on l'a alors les
études sont très très contradictoires
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
les premiers jours ça ressemble aux non
vaccinés et il ya un certain nombre
d'études qui disent que ça s'arrête plus
rapidement chez les vaccinés que chez
les non vaccinés donc
c'est certes une bombe mais c'est pas
une bombe à retardement qui sautent qui
se répète c'est
disons que le risque à long terme 15
jours ou une semaine et est plus faible
on va me manche et des pacsés dernière
question puisqu'on parle évidemment
beaucoup de l'autriche il ya eu ce débat
en français ce que le gouvernement ira
jusque là en tout cas certains candidats
notamment du côté des élèves mederi
pécresse où vous avez bertrand le
demande de confiner les non-vaccinés
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire vous
son plan politique c'est la course à
l'échalote à celui qui fera plus que
l'autre candidat la réalité c'est que
sur les 10-12 % de personnes non
vaccinées et on a la moitié qui sont des
personnes âgées des parents n'est pas né
qui sont très isolés et si on veut les
vaccinés fois les chez eux chez elle et
les joindre directement ce pour ma part
fait du tout en france et puis il ya 5 %
d'irréductibles et ce n'est pas en les
confinant qu' il y aura une inefficacité
tellement importante dans moi je ne
pense pas vraiment que ce confinement a
réservé aux eaux non vaccinés serve à
quelque chose c'est plus sûr c'est plus
quelque chose pour
impressionner autrichien qui ne se sont
pas assez précipités vers les centres de
vaccination
merci beaucoup philippe froguel
chercheur généticien professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université lille 2 merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct